mother yes sit so do you remember five
nights at freddys yes I do you remember
how we played him before who died now
remember ooh yeah what do you think of
that guy hey you know words just yeah
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to my mom plays five
minutes at freddy's so grab that mouse
and click new game how do you know my
mouse works I never used Mouse what I
use finger what how do you do come on
show you things we've done two other
videos over the past two years with this
modern it's not what are you Paul you
what this is the click button okay and
see okay see oh my god
this controls that you see how that
works yeah you've used a mouse before
long time ago it's been a while a year
yeah
come on let's go all right so grab on
this now just get familiarize yourself
because the mouse is the only way this
game is controlled see how that works
now click on new game
left click there you go okay where this
is five nights at Freddy's 3 so you
remember Freddie
yes you remember Bonnie yes you remember
chica of course throw them all out the
window they're gone yeah where are they
they're dead
we'll kill yo you just have to wait and
see you mute this call you don't even
need to know about munich munich munich
click on this click here you don't need
it
listen to me you move the mouse to the
right you'll go right you move it to the
left go left now when you're all the way
left you'll have a little orange box
here click on that up pops your restart
mint so this reboots all your systems
when they break down overnight you won't
need to worry about it right now
but if a device breaks you'll have to
come over to the left click and restart
hit exit now go back to the right now
click here in this blue box this shows
your map you've got all these different
cameras 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 now it's
numbered like this because the enemy you
know the guy in the main menu what's his
thing what do you think his name is
he's a very like mechanical monstrous
she's not Freddy he's not Freddy you can
call him Freddy if you want but it's not
Freddy it's Freddy he's free ok alright
so click on camera 10 okay he's not here
is it my dear
right there my dear that's Freddy I
don't know no it's not Freddy that's a
poster blister look I'm supposed to
click on camera 9 no we're looking for
Freddy
ok 9 plate okay not there he may not be
in the building yet it's only the first
night so you know it's an easy night now
click on 8 what's that
pumpkin or chica chica yeah pumpkin all
right let's go with pumpkin I think
pumpkin nobody alright number 7 yeah
who's that
nobody nobody nobody all right number 6
no whole-body number 5 nobody nobody
number 4
who's that nothing nothing
that's nothing nothing nothing nothing
is some kind of a decoration decoration
you're right
you're actually right these were all
decorations so this is supposed to be
like a haunted house this is way in the
future from when the other two games
were so when when the whole place was
like shut down someone decided they were
going to build a horror house with a
bunch of five nights at Freddy's themed
stuff so they put all these things on
the wall old decorations from the old
pizzerias because they heard about the
murders that happened to the kids in the
pizzeria and they're like we're gonna
reenact this story and make it
terrifying and as realistic as we
possibly can you know what I mean so you
we die
Freddy Freddy that's a Freddy that's
Freddy
okay might be Bonnie maybe Bonnie I'm
not sure hmm Broly Freddy look on number
one you oh yeah yeah exit okay so we
just went through the entire attraction
from ten to one is the haunted house
it's like the path of it okay so that's
where people would go if they were
enjoying their time here now last thing
click on map toggle right there okay
this is the ventilation system this is
where you don't want them going why
because then they can get to you there's
even a direct path right here that gets
them right - I said that's all bad yeah
it's all done ahh anyway you survived
the first night easy Oh easy easy
easiest things I get painful did you get
paid I can't do this you can do this see
it's easy oh oh alright this is a
minigame now using W a s and D you can
move up down left and right put your
fingers right here so go down yeah yeah
what am i moving your this guy oh I'm
the one yeah person hold the keep moving
oh yeah my Chloe
oh no no follow I know what there was a
thing that went through this door oh I
need to find out that go up
but uh do I follow what there was
something they went off to the right man
oh it's just this way okay send a blood
stain follow oh it's too hard it's too
hard
there you go you've got this I believe
in you oh yeah see you're getting it
you're getting it it's easy okay you're
gonna get him you're gonna get him go
get him
Aira I did something wrong did something
wrong scary hey I didn't get to do
anything fun no you didn't know
well you're still learning but it's
night - now mute that call you don't
need to know about that alright now go
over to the right click on the blue
button ok turn out to camera - so what
should I do you need to look for the
monster oh yeah Freddy no that's that's
the decoration oh yeah keep looking
around where you really get startled by
the Pope yeah so like the other games
it's just watching out for where they
are they're hiding real well yeah come
on
Oh video error okay your video feed just
broke you need to fix it so click the
blue button move your mouse all the way
left click the orange button and then
restart your camera system click on that
and then it'll take some time but 3 2 1
fixed all right now you can exit and
then go back to the cameras you doing
great mom am i yeah alright so your
ventilations Brooke you need to click
the orange button now click the
ventilation you all right good okay yeah
you're good hit exit ok now go back to
the right well click on blue if you see
something like that pop up you gotta
close the camera super fast by clicking
the blue button again ok if you see
something like that ok be careful ok
0:01
oh wait go back go back to 9 what's that
nothing like are you sure mm-hmm
are you sure it's nothing yeah you're
sure it's nothing ok you're probably
right that's probably nothing nothing
wait go back there go 7 Oh your camera
broke you gotta go fix it like that go
left
hit the orange okay camera good
stressful huh my boys are gonna go high
today
Oh risk of stroke
[Music]
wait go back tonight no no I no like
annihilate you nothing oh it's gone yeah
you're right it was nothing they know
they know they know your ventilation is
broken
Oh give you a break you're good there's
nothing that's gonna pop up here maybe
Oh what's there
that's your ventilation exit yeah you're
good okay go back to the right now look
for the monster you gotta find it before
it finds you oh wait for me it's too
quick okay so as soon as I saw the shade
shadow I need to go this way way maybe
let's do one more time no more travel
say good night yeah
secondly I uh I need to go up to six
hours right yes you almost made it last
time you almost made it yeah so this is
all good go over to the right hit the
blue button I'm gonna find it find it
yeah that's the trick you got a fin
that's usually where the monster first
appears really yeah seven six five wait
click this go map toggle cuz he can be
here too in the vents that's how we got
so close so quick it's not here not here
okay go back to the other map okay I'm
gonna catch you you gonna catch him yeah
you're gonna I gotta catch you catch hmm
6oh your videos up again yeah you know
how to fix it yeah you know you're smart
you're smart yeah you're smart you're a
smart cookie thinks you're smart yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you a trick huh
Kitson I'm sure you trick go right click
that click on like eight and hit this
button oh yeah oh yeah I might know
go do I do look like good you're good
you're good okay is it those good
instincts okay let's get hit exit okay
you need to go back okay he's gone so
you want to lure him back there again
hit the audio lure again hi I hear you I
what do you them in it didn't work
your ventilation is broken you need to
go fix it it's orange ventilation you
got your good get back in the games to
play
I'm play Hey exit okay so go back to
eight seeping in the room again so he's
not coming back which either means he's
too far away or Matt Matt Matt he might
be near you try playing audio in four
hit that hit reboot audio okay okay
you're doing great you're doing great
okay mom doing great
I believe in you I'm so proud of you go
here restart your camera in this game
fun games fun right if I can survive -
oh yes yes fun and now come on okay go
back to camera alright so I don't know
where he is but he's got to be close to
you he's got to be in like one or two
oh honey so neat to be a.m. oh my gosh
yeah come on click on four full full
full where are you Oh use the audio
audio hello yeah hello
what's there mean it's it's just a noise
Oh left I need I need to kill my time
here yeah
where's kill time it's a Tokyo or
something like that the red it's fine
probably I don't remember what the red
is but it's probably fine ten ten ten no
three three three two one why I don't
know where it is
oh this is hit five Harvey audio hey
[Music]
that's okay
if it's any consolation you were six
nights away from winning anyway really
yeah yeah you were great
yeah that's good thing last time I beat
it it was up to six up yeah you be the
lesson you can if you want yeah go for
it it's fun it's fun yeah
you want to win yeah you'll win what mom
load game I'm gonna get you I'm gonna
get you I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get
you so you know you know the basic
premise right I think so yeah it's all
about keeping track of where he is cuz
when you find him then you can control
them with the audio how do I control
that guy when you know that little hello
uh-huh that's not calling to you that's
not him it's calling to him to bring him
to where you're clicking it right yeah
if he gets close to around here you're
in trouble so you want to lure him to
like the 5/8 area you want to keep him
there that's it yeah the light is in
five yeah you want to lure him to eight
so click on eight okay click play audio
okay oh hi oh it didn't work which means
he must have moved so go back to five he
must be in to two or maybe he's in for
full he's moving fast hit five play
audio hey
oh there he is oh come on what do I need
to do oh you need to fix your video oh
he's moving fast tonight I don't know
why he knows you're getting good all
right he's in five try to get him to six
six maybe six play audio there hey
nothing is left Oh eggs no you got a
reboot go back yeah your systems are
breaking you get a fix them oh go back
to the orange click here now you got two
Bourbons so just hit reboot all and
it'll reboot everything oh my goodness
it's ok it's ok it's ok it takes a
little longer when you reboot it home
try to lure him back to 5 & 6 5 try 5 hi
hi where are you where are you cuz
you're I did see that thing that's a
monster I was on the camera look here
fix audio yeah
it's okay you got this is it me sound
terrible there is you're fine you're
alive you're okay oh okay
I'm still surviving I'm still go to to
click on to ah
[Music]
go three
I think you might be dead
try 525 hit the audio hello come on oh
okay he's not there so that's that's
good he's not there I think you might
have done it I think you might have done
it you might have done it all right now
hit that put the audio go right on - -
yeah do two audio no no go five play
audio your audio broken almost there
4:00 a.m. it's got to be close to 5:00
a.m. you're so close you've got this as
soon as that's fixed drop that down go
back to right you're gonna go back to
five you're gonna hit it again right
here hi whoa there he is it worked
oh listen I don't next you're gonna try
to get him to six Souza's cut dots come
up oh no go hello when I oh it worked I
think it worked
go back to six oh here's something your
ventilation air ok go here come on
you're so close 5 a.m. one hour left
you're so close okay a ventilation you
got this mom you got this you got this
what you gotta do is once you hit exit
hit exit hit I got it okay go right
click that open hello
come on there he's there hello that's
his arm oh yeah what should I go go to
seven next time try to get him pull him
into seven hit audio hello
[Music]
oh it is so excited yeah congratulations
you actually beat it all on your own you
did it
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this next Christmas
we'll be playing the next five nights at
Freddy's five nights at Freddy's 4 which
is a very different experience yeah oh
yeah very damn so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next video well done mom
[Music]